i think there are aliens seem to think i
think they're aliens
these are full of [ __ ] i don't i just
think they haven't been here i think
they're i don't think we're the only
people in the universe
i just think it is so crazy to think
that we have all of these cameras
and detection satellites so you don't
think the government's ever seen aliens
even though
and this was during the middle of the
pandemic the white house confirmed
that they have ufos they have them in
their possession that are from
an unknown world they confirm they have
ufos
i think well they say that but they
confirm
they have technology they they can't
confirm they said
they said they found parts from a crash
but
it's not they said it was also like a an
arbitrary
like consultant so it wasn't really the
pentagon or anything so it was a
consultant that said that i've never
seen this from this world
i think honestly that it's just
technology that we don't have yet
china or russia more likely that i think
it's trying to rush more likely we're
seen
more likely yeah technology that we have
never seen so far
but by the way i think
that there are things out there i think
there's probably
an earth somewhere out there that
mirrors this
pretty closely 100 i just
i just have a hard time believing that a
they came here but only in the 50s when
we didn't have the technology to
really keep track of them coming well
they've been here since
but did you see that what about the
military video where you
military pilots and it's in the ocean
the way they move and the speed they
move and the temperature they're like
we don't know we literally can't tell
you yeah i can't keep up with it
when it flies too low the temperature
would be at negative
30 like anything that fast we can't see
the motor we can't see the with the
propulsion
and it's it's like small enough to where
a human being couldn't fit in it
so i think drones to be honest yeah and
and my my only just crazy drone
technology
yeah my my only thing is this is like
why
would they be so scared of us are they
if they're so much more advanced than us
no they're coming just like how these
people are [ __ ] here but like no
i just it's hard for me to to really
take in that there's been
no contact there's been no definitive
sighting hold on no contact that the
government's gonna tell you about
okay so no contact i mean why but why
hasn't
nobody else in the entire world with
like i said with all the technology we
have
now nobody like china and russia tell us
no the [ __ ] just regular citizens with
buying
with telescopes that can see wherever
the [ __ ] i just mean there's so many
so many people have said they've seen
stuff though said they've seen stuff so
many people have said they've seen
bigfoot too i mean look until
until
why are they anal probing like why is
that the one move that everybody's
gonna be talking about i i think they
have been here
i do i i've told you i believe i i don't
think that bob lasers complete
full of [ __ ] when you hear a story like
after all these years you think he'd
have some hiccup in his lies like
there's
the detail and he talks about working on
the on the
on ufos that they have at area 51 for
the government
yeah trying to figure out the the elect
the the
technology behind it dude can i tell you
i
hope there are like these aren't things
like i hope there are
i would love i think that's fascinating
obviously that's [ __ ]
understating it i hope there are aliens
i hope they come down and go
hey you know we can do this you want to
do this i hope they're cool and then we
all get along
i just don't think it has happened i for
me i don't think what's this
i saw this on yahoo a little while ago
so i guess a russian
astronaut that's staying on the
international space station
wanted to capture that aurora borealis
so he had this like uh
yeah you know the time lapse video yeah
and he captures some things around like
the nine second market thing so i'll
show you
i don't know this is the whole long one
so i'm not sure if this the one i saw
capture that nine seconds in on the
original
the yahoo video but let's see
[Music]
that is so [ __ ] cool though
wait do you think that's an alien no no
so that's the aurora borealis
let me find the original video you guys
can be let me ask you something you
watched the
show away have you seen it it basically
there's a mission to mars it's going to
take three years okay if you
had the opportunity to go into space but
i'm would you not do it no
the three years away from everybody i
but that seems like would you do that
would you go away the [ __ ] am i gonna do
when i get up there
like would you would you do that i mean
what is up there i don't think i'm
curious enough
about space to you know dedicate three
years of my life to it bummer when we
get up there
i i guess to say that you were in space
and landed on mars like
no and but but you're probably i don't
know how many people have landed on mars
it can't be very many if
if any people none right so
this show is about landing and and but
you wouldn't be
to go to them i don't know how long does
it take to get to the moon no idea
would you no desire you're no desire no
desire to go to the moon either
how's it going for buzz i mean but but
he can say he was killing it
no but what a crazy experience you don't
care at all not at all you're not
curious at all to know
three day you wouldn't take three days
out of your life
to get in a [ __ ] rocket ship instead
of going to hilarities in cleveland nope
i'm gonna say
i'm going to send you to the [ __ ]
moon no what am i going to do dude
you're going to be on the moon bro yeah
i'm going to tell you how was the moon
ah dude
but you i was out there we were like oh
that's cool but you've got pros
the earth from the moon you get to be in
space
that is mind-boggling you desire at all
neither one of you any too risky for me
me too too risky
oh [ __ ] goes bad too i don't like flying
oh
dude i think every time it flies a risk
and i hate it yeah i [ __ ] hate flying
too long to the
moon
three days three days you want to take a
three-day plane ride no but i'll take a
straight up
[ __ ] on a rocket ship yeah dude you want
to do that get all the gear
float around for a little while that
would be so dope how cool would it be to
be high
with no gravity zero design i'm not sure
if they'd let me take any edibles on the
tree
they went up they're like hey we've been
up there for 10 years they built a city
it's
better than vegas there's tons of cool
people up there restaurants
you go to the moon to get a meal bro i
need something more than just
walking around and then telling people
no people like yeah dude yeah we saw
buzz aldrin
won't shut up about it he like does
seminars now talking about it
i i i would
i would maybe mars seems too long he
went to the moon
and then kate let's say you went to the
moon tonight yeah came back on the show
on monday you wouldn't have any
questions for me
how was it dude you go oh it's cool man
i like walked around like that's cool
anyways what else you got chance what
are we gonna talk about well i don't
know i haven't been to the moon yet it's
like you tell me a girl you hooked up
with
i don't give a [ __ ] dude i wasn't there
i can i can bring up pictures on [ __ ]
google
but but but but you would you would swim
go underwater swim with sharks and do
all that stuff
yeah but i wouldn't come back and like
talk your ear off about it because you
weren't there
yeah but what a crazy experience to
share with people
yeah have you heard buzz aldrin talking
like oh my god 190 years old
when he was young you watch the
interviews like all right cool dude i
no i for me things like that that
very few people i'd rather watch gravity
with george clooney
oh my god i have no desire no one's
gonna give a flying [ __ ] dude
jeez are you kidding no one would care
okay so buzz aldrin you just said is
still giving talks
because that's all he had 170 years
after he did it
people are still curious no they're not
nobody gets to do it
so i bet he opens up any questions what
was it like on the moon
you know pretty dark uh it's cold up
there i'm out
i'm out i don't give a [ __ ]
you would you yeah man what question
would you ask buzz aldrin that he has
answered a hundred million times that i
couldn't get from george clooney and
gravity
i don't what do you what would you ask
him what did you ask him well here's his
name what was it like
the things that i would ask him he
couldn't give me a satisfactory answer
to because i would have to experience it
correct
so i would love to be in a i want to
know what it's like that kind of g-force
taking off
i want to know what it's like just
basically floating through space i want
to know what it looks like
up there i want to i want to see
i just want to only one way to find out
josh do it
do it yeah and then keep it to yourself
because we cuz we don't give up
like if someone said hey buzz aldrin's
come on the podcast
i'm like all right i guess
you know it's like we weren't there
keep it to yourself dude what else you
got jen
want some more uh is that it uh we have
let's get let's end on all right we're
28 i mean if you go dude i guess
shoot me attack i won't i'm not even
going to let you know man you know what
send me a selfie i guess
i might be you know if you took a selfie
on the moon
the moon with the earth behind me like
this i'm like oh damn that's crazy have
fun man
that's it not yet you're not even asking
and you're like whatever
i mean i guess it'd be a good pr move
you're like okay i'll be hilarity's next
weekend
yeah you're gonna be your cell service
up there yeah dude how's the merch
are we gonna do with that dude do you
see any animals
no there's nothing up there dude i can't
even believe there's nothing up no it's
the moon how was it
dude is pretty just what you expect when
off the movies uh pretty cold
darkest [ __ ] nothing else was out here
oh my god
well you i definitely not gonna tell you
next time i go
that's it i'm not done when i go to the
moon dude guess who's not hearing about
it you [ __ ]
you're gonna miss out am i everybody
else is gonna hear the moon stories dude
not you around the comments here joshua
the move damn that's crazy yeah dude
what do you do he told me not to tell
you he just kind of like walked around
he was like dark and that's it man and
then he came back three days later
everyone's like that's a fun story i
guess yeah good for josh
meanwhile i mean i it's so funny that
you're like i would definitely take
hilarities
100 over the moon walk 100 i will tell
you this though
if you told me i could learn how to
moonwalk like michael jackson i would
take that moonwalk
over the actual moon we can do that can
you moonwalk like michael jackson no
but i guarantee i could find someone to
teach me do you know what that's more
impressive than you going to the moon
josh oh
my god i think buzz has any talent
no dude they put him in the suit because
there's good eyesight do you think
that's easy to be an astronaut if that's
what you want to do and you're the and
you have a high level iq and you can see
straight you know if you have good
vision it's not
impressive are you impressed by
astronauts
yeah man i think the training to be an
astronaut is kind of pretty extensive
yeah i'm more impressed with navy
seals they're all so impressive i can be
impressed with two different people
yeah but i'm not like are you are you
buying uh like uh
an astronaut t-shirt like i don't know
i'm probably not
by i'm more impressed with like fighter
pilots than the guys going the moon
yeah fighter pilots too also so i'm more
impressed with the guy who built the
spaceship
me too not the guy who sat there like
this
i i think they're all you know they're
not even driving it
you know they're it's controlled from
down below doing
something dude it's not a remote control
car that is no it's not they gotta flick
buttons and [ __ ] no they do this you
don't think they do three
two four and they do that the whole
and for the whole time they're just
floating around and then they get out
they take a leisurely stroll and get the
[ __ ] back in
oh my god are you i'm not impressed with
astronauts apparently not they got balls
i respect what they do but
all right but they're put there it's
just right
what's more impressed with the gathering
got me what's more impressive say the
nascar driver astronaut
nascar driver okay all right
how about when i get off stage with the
lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together on
i'm just saying dude grab that mic son